it's et social study what stars are
posting online Madonna
sets the record straight on her
controversial comments about blowing up
the white house in her women's March
speech the pop superstar took to
Instagram Sunday to clarify writing in
part I am NOT a violent person
I do not promote violence adding quote I
spoke in a metaphor and I shared two
ways of looking at things
one was to be hopeful and one was to
feel anger and outrage which I have
personally felt I'm very happy Kim
Kardashian is still reminiscing over her
trip to Dubai
the reality star Instagram a series
snaps from her time abroad noting her
favorite part of the trip was visiting
Rashid Pediatric Therapy Center I love
that olivia munn thanked fans for
supporting her boyfriend Aaron Rodgers
in the Green Bay Packers after Sunday's
loss that cost them a spot at the Super
Bowl
Wow Gisele Bundchen congratulated her
husband Tom Brady on his seventh trip to
the Super Bowl after the Patriots won
next Katie Holmes shares a sweet
throwback with her strong and beautiful
mom Kathleen Paris so big and so amazing
and happy meanwhile JLo is making time
for her twins as she works on her
upcoming Spanish album Lopez posted this
adorable pic in the recording studio
kissing Emmie while max hugged them from
behind and Teen Mom 2 star Jenelle Evans
is doing any day now here's the expected
mom happy and healthy as she awaits the
arrival of baby number three